[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIANE GREENE: Hello.
FEI-FEI LI: Hi.
DIANE GREENE: Who's
interested in AI?
[CHEERING]
Me too.
Me three.
OK.
So I'm the moderator today.
I'm Diane Greene, and
I'm running Google Cloud
and on the Alphabet board.
And I'm going to
briefly introduce
our really amazing
guests we have here.
I also live on the
Stanford campus,
so I've known one of our
guests for a long time,
because she's a neighbor.
So let me just introduce them.
First is Dr. Fei-Fei Li, and
she is the Chief Scientist
for Google Cloud.
She also runs AI Lab at Stanford
University, the Vision Lab,
and then she also
founded SAILORS,
which is now
AI4ALL, which you'll
hear about a little bit later.
And is there anything you
want to add to that, Fei-Fei?
FEI-FEI LI: I'm your neighbor.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the best.
DIANE GREENE: And so now
we have Greg Corrado.
And actually there's
one amazing coincidence.
Both Fei-Fei and Greg were
undergraduate physics majors
at Princeton together
at the same time.
And didn't really know
each other that well
in the 18-person class.
FEI-FEI LI: We were
studying too hard.
GREG CORRADO: No, it was
kind of surprising to go
to undergrad together, neither
of us in computer science,
and then rejoin later only
once we were here at Google.
DIANE GREENE: All paths lead
to AI and neural networks
and so forth.
But anyhow, so Greg is
the Principal Scientist
in the Google Brain Group.
He co-founded it.
And more recently,
he's been doing
a lot of amazing work in
health with neural networks
and machine learning.
He has a PhD in
neuroscience from Stanford.
And so he came into AI in
a very interesting way.
And maybe he'll talk about the
similarities between the brain
and what's going on in AI.
Would you like to
add anything else?
GREG CORRADO: No, sounds good.
DIANE GREENE: OK.
So I thought since both of them
have been involved in the AI
field for a while
and it's recently
become a really
big deal, but it'd
be nice to get a little
perspective on the history,
yours in Vision and yours
in neuroscience, about AI
and how it was so natural for
it to evolve to where it is now
and what you're doing.
And start with Fei-Fei.
FEI-FEI LI: I guess I'll start.
So first of all, AI is
a very nascent field
in the history of science
of human civilization.
This is a field of
only 60 years of age.
And it started with a very, very
simple but fundamental quest--
is can machines think?
And we all know thinkers
and thought leaders
like Alan Turing challenged
humanity with that question.
Can machines think?
So about 60 years ago, a group
of very pioneering scientists,
computer scientists like
Marvin Minsky, John McCarthy,
started really this field.
In fact, John McCarthy, who
founded Stanford's AI lab,
coined the very word
artificial intelligence.
So where do we begin to
build machines that think?
Humanity is best at
looking inward in ourselves
and try to draw inspiration
from who we are.
So we started thinking
about building machines that
resemble human thinking.
And when you think about
human intelligence,
you start thinking about
different aspects like ability
to reason and ability
to see and ability
to hear, to speak, to move
around, make decisions,
manipulate.
So AI started from that very
core, foundational dream
60 years ago, started
to proliferate
as a field of multiple subfield,
which includes robotics,
computer vision, natural
language processing,
speech recognition.
And then a very
important development
happened around
the '80s and '90s,
which is a sister field called
machine learning started
to blossom.
And that's a field combining
statistical learnings,
statistics, with
computer science.
And combining the quest of
machine intelligence, which
is what AI was born out of,
with the tools and capabilities
of machine learning.
AI as a field went
through an extremely
fruitful, productive,
blossoming period of time.
And fast-forward to the
second decade of 21st century.
The latest machine learning
booming that we are observing
is called deep
learning, which has
a deep root in neuroscience,
which I'll let you talk about.
And so combining
deep learning as
a powerful statistical
machine learning tool
with the quest of making
machines more intelligent.
Whether it's to see or is
it to hear or to speak,
we're seeing this blossom.
And last I just want to
say, three critical factors
converged around
the last decade,
which is the 2000s and the
beginning of 2010s, which are
the three computing factors.
One is the advance
of hardware that
enabled more powerful
and capable computing.
Second is the
emergence of big data,
powerful data that can drive
the statistical learning
algorithms.
And I was lucky to be involved
myself in some of the effort.
And then the third one is the
advances of machine learning
and deep learning algorithms.
So this convergence
of three major factors
brought us the AI boom
that we're seeing today.
And Google has been
investing in all three areas,
honestly, earlier
than the curve.
Most of the effort started
even in early 2000s.
And as a company, we're
doing a lot of AI work
from research to products.
GREG CORRADO: And it's been
really interesting to watch
the divergence in exploration
in various academic fields
and then the re-convergence as
we see ideas that are aligned.
So it wasn't, as Fei-Fei
says, it wasn't so long
ago that fields like cognitive
science, neuroscience,
artificial intelligence,
even things
that we don't talk about
much more like cybernetics,
were really all aligned
in a single discipline.
And then they've moved
apart from each other
and explored these
ideas independently
for a couple of decades.
And then with the renaissance
in artificial neural networks
and deep learning,
we're starting
to see some re-convergence.
So some of these ideas
that were popular
only in a small community
for a couple of decades
are now coming back
into the mainstream
of what artificial intelligence
is, what statistical pattern
recognition is, and it's
really been delightful to see.
But it's not just one idea.
It's actually multiple
ideas that you
see that were maintained
for a long time in fields
like cognitive science that
are coming back into the fold.
So another example
beyond deep learning
is actually
reinforcement learning.
So for the longest time, if
you looked at a university
catalog of courses
and you were looking
for any mention of reinforcement
learning whatsoever,
you were going to find
it in a psychology
department or a cognitive
science department.
But today, as we
all know, we look
at reinforcement learning
as a new opportunity,
as something that
we actually look
at for the future of AI that
might be something that's
important to get
machines to really learn
in completely
dynamic environments,
in environments where they
have to explore entirely
new stimuli.
So I've been really excited to
see how this convergence has
happened back in the
direction from those ideas
into mainstream
computer science.
And I think that there's
some hope for exchange
back in the other direction.
So neuroscientists and
cognitive scientists
today are starting
to ask whether we
can take the kind of
computer vision models
that Fei-Fei helped pioneer and
use those as hypotheses for how
it is that neural systems
actually compute, how
our own biological brains see.
And I think that
that's really exciting
to see this kind of
exchange between disciplines
that have been separated
for a little while.
DIANE GREENE: You know, one
little piece of history I think
that's also interesting
is what you did, Fei-Fei,
with ImageNet, which is a nice
way of explaining building
these neural networks where
you labeled all these images
and then people could
refine their algorithms by--
go ahead and explain
that just real quickly.
FEI-FEI LI: OK, sure.
So about 10 years ago, the whole
community of computer vision,
which is a subfield of AI, was
working on a holy grail problem
of object recognition,
which is you open your eyes,
you can see the
world full of objects
like flowers, chairs, people.
And that's a building block
of visual intelligence
and intelligence in general.
And to crack that problem,
we were building, as a field,
different machine
learning models.
We're making small progress, but
we're hitting a lot of walls.
And when my student and I
started working on this problem
and started thinking
deeply about what
is missing in the way we're
approaching this problem,
we recognize this
important interplay
between data as statistical
machine learning models.
They really reinforce each other
in very deep mathematical ways
that we're not going to
talk about the details here.
That realization was also
inspired by human vision.
If you look at how
children learn,
it's a lot of learning
through big data
experiences and exploration.
So combining that, we
decided to put together
a pretty epic
effort of we wanted
to label all the images we
can get on the internet.
And of course, we
Google Searched a lot
and we downloaded
billions of images
and used crowdsourcing
technology
to label all the
images, organize them
into a data set of 50
million images, organized
in 22,000 categories of
objects, and put that together,
and that's the ImageNet project.
And we democratized it
to the research world
and released the open source.
And then starting
in 2010, we held
an international challenge
for the whole AI community
called ImageNet Challenge.
And one of the
teams from Toronto,
which is now at Google,
won the ImageNet Challenge
with the deep learning
convolutional neural network
model.
And that was year 2012.
And a lot of people think
the combination of ImageNet
and the deep learning
model in 2012
was the onset of what Greg--
DIANE GREENE: A way to
compare how they were doing.
And it was really good.
So yeah.
And so Greg, you've been doing a
lot of brain-inspired research,
very interesting research.
And I know you've been doing a
lot of very impactful research
in the health area.
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
GREG CORRADO: Sure.
So I mean, I think the
ImageNet example actually
sort of sets a
playbook for how we
can try to approach a problem.
The kind of machine
learning and AI
that is most practical
and most useful today
is ones where machines
learn through imitation.
It's an imitation game
where if you have examples
of a task being
performed correctly,
the machine can learn
to imitate this.
And this is called
supervised learning.
And so what happened in
the image recognition
case is that by Fei-Fei building
an object recognition data set,
we could all focus
on that problem
in a really concrete,
tractable way
in order to compare
different methods.
And it turned out that
methods like deep learning
and artificial
neural networks were
able to do something really
interesting in that space
that previous machine learning
and artificial intelligence
methods had not, which was that
they were able to go directly
from the data to the predictions
and break the problem up
into many smaller steps
without having being
told exactly how to do that.
So that's what we were doing
before is that we were trying
to engineer features or cues,
things that we could see
in the stimuli that
then we would do
a little bit of statistical
learning on to figure out
how to combine these signals.
But with artificial neural
networks and deep learning,
we're actually learning to
do those things all together.
And this applies not
only to computer vision,
but it applies to most
things that you could
imagine a machine imitating.
And so the kinds of
things that we've
done like with Google Smart
Reply and now Smart Compose,
we're taking that same approach.
That if you have a lot of
text data, which it turns out
the internet is full of,
what you can actually do
is you can look at
the sequence of words
so far in a conversation
or in an email exchange
and try to guess
what comes next.
DIANE GREENE: I'm going to
interrupt here a little bit
and get a little more
provocative here.
GREG CORRADO: All right.
DIANE GREENE: So you're talking
about neural-inspired machine
learning and so forth.
And so this artificial
intelligence
is kind of bringing into
question what are we humans?
And then there's
this thing out there
called AGI, Artificial
General Intelligence.
What do you think's
going on here?
Are we getting to AGI?
GREG CORRADO: I
really don't think so.
So there's a variety of
opinions in the community.
But my feeling is
that, OK, we've finally
gotten artificial
neural networks
to be able to recognize
photos of cats.
That's really great.
We also now can--
DIANE GREENE: Fei-Fei, was that
AGI when we recognized a cat?
FEI-FEI LI: No.
That's not enough to define AGI.
GREG CORRADO: So the kind of
thing that's working well right
now is this sort of
pattern recognition,
this immediate response
where we're able to recognize
something kind of reflexively.
And we now have, I
believe, machines
can do pattern recognition
every bit as well as humans can.
And that's why they
can recognize objects
in photos, that's why they
can do speech recognition,
and that's why they can
win at a game like Go.
But that is only one small
sliver, a tiny sliver,
of what goes into something
like intelligence.
Notions of memory and
planning and strategy
and contingencies, even
emotional intelligence, these
are things that we haven't
even scratched the surface.
And so to me, I feel
like it's really a leap
too far to imagine that
having finally cracked pattern
recognition, after
some decades of trying,
that we are therefore on
the verge of cracking all
of these other problems that
go into what constitutes
general intelligence.
DIANE GREENE:
Although we have gone
way faster than either of
you ever expected us to go,
I believe.
FEI-FEI LI: Yes and no.
Humanity has a tendency
to overestimate
short-term progress
and underestimate
long-term progress.
So eventually, we will be
achieving things that we cannot
dream of.
But Diane and Greg, I want
to just give a simple example
to define AGI.
So the definition of AGI, again,
is an introspective definition
of what humans and human
intelligence can do.
I have a two-year-old daughter
who doesn't like napping.
And I thought I'm
smart enough to scheme
to put her in a very complicated
sleeping bag that doesn't
get herself out of the crib.
And just a couple
of months ago, I
was on the monitor watching
this kid, two-year-old,
where for the first
time I was training her
for napping by herself.
She was very angry.
So she looked around, figured
out a weak spot on the crib
where she might be
able to climb out,
figured out how to unzip
her complicated sleeping
bag that I thought I schemed
to try to prevent that,
and figured out a
way to climb out
of a crib that's
way taller than who
she is and managed
to escape safely
and without breaking her legs.
DIANE GREENE: OK, how about
AGI equivalent to my cat
or equivalent to a mouse?
FEI-FEI LI: If you're
shifting the definition, sure.
DIANE GREENE: I see, OK.
FEI-FEI LI: But
even cat, I think
there are things that a
cat is capable of doing.
GREG CORRADO: So I
do think that if you
look at an organism like a
cat from a behavioral level,
like how cats behave
and how they respond
to their environments, I
think that you could imagine
a world where you have
something like a toy that
is for entertainment
purposes that approximates
a cat in a bunch of ways in
that the sorts of behaviors
that the human observe, you're
like, oh, it walks around.
It doesn't bump into things.
It meows at me every
once in a while.
I do believe that we can
build a system like that.
But what you can't do is
you can't take that robot
and then dump it in the
forest and have it figure out
what it needs to do in order to
survive and make things work.
FEI-FEI LI: But it's a goal.
It's a healthy goal.
DIANE GREENE: It's
a healthy goal.
And along the way, at
least we all three agree
that AI's capacity to help
us solve all our big problems
is going to outweigh
any kind of negative,
and we're pretty excited
about that, I guess.
In Cloud, you're kind of doing
some cool things with AutoML
and so forth.
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah,
so we talk a lot,
Diane, about the belief of
building benevolent technology
for human use.
Our technology
reflect our values.
So I personally, and I know
Greg's whole team is working
on bringing AI to people and to
the fields that really need it
to make a positive difference.
So at Cloud, we're very lucky
to be working with customers
and partners from all kinds
of vertical industries,
from health care
where we collaborate,
to agriculture,
to sustainability,
to entertainment, to retail,
to commerce, to finance, where
our customers bring some of the
toughest problem and their pain
points, and we can work
with them hand-in-hand
to solve some of that.
So for example, recently
we rolled out AutoML.
And that is the
recognition of the pain
of entering machine learning.
It's still a highly
technical field.
The bar is still high.
Not enough people
are trained experts
in the world of
machine learning.
But yet our industry
already has so much need
to tag pictures, understand
imageries, just as an example,
in vision.
So how do we answer
that call of need?
So we've worked hard and
thought about this suite
of product called AutoML
where the customer--
we lower the entry
barrier by relieving them
from coding machine learning
custom models themselves.
All they have to
do is to give us
the kind of-- provide the kind
of data and concept they need.
Here's an example of a
ramen company in Tokyo
that has many shops
of ramens and they
want to build an app
that recognize the ramens
from different ramen stores.
And they give us the
pictures of ramens
and the concepts of their store.
One store, two store, three.
And what we do is
to use a technique,
a machine learning technique
that Google and many others
have developed called
learning to learn, and then
build a customized model for the
customer that recognize ramens
for their different stores.
And then the customer
can take that model
to do what they want.
DIANE GREENE: I can
write a little C++,
maybe some JavaScript.
Could I do AutoML?
FEI-FEI LI: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
We're working with teams that
they don't have not even C++
experience.
And we have a drag
and drop interface,
and you can use AutoML that way.
GREG CORRADO: Because I really
believe that there are so
many problems that can be solved
using this technique that it's
critical that we share as
much as possible about how
these things work.
I don't believe that
these technologies should
live in walled
gardens, but instead we
should develop tools
that can be used
by everyone in the community.
And that's part of why we have
a very aggressive open source
stance to our software
packages, particularly in AI.
And that includes
things like TensorFlow
that are available
completely freely,
and it includes the
kinds of services
that are available on Cloud
to do the kind of compute,
storage, and model tuning and
serving that you need to use
these things in practice.
And I think it's amazing
that the same tools
that my applied
machine learning team
uses to tackle problems
that we're interested
in, those same tools are
accessible to all of you
as well to try to solve the
same problems in the same way.
And I've been really excited
with how great the uptake is
and how we're seeing
expanding to other languages.
Mentioning JavaScript.
Quick plug for tensorflow.js
is actually really awesome.
DIANE GREENE: Oh, and you
should probably run it on a TPU.
GREG CORRADO: Yes, exactly.
DIANE GREENE: It does
give a nice boost.
So you're building, I mean,
with machine learning,
we're bringing it to
market in so many ways,
because we have the tools
to build your own models,
the TensorFlow.
We have the AutoML that
brings it to any programmer.
And then what's going
on with all the APIs,
and how is that going to
affect every industry,
and what do you
see going on there?
FEI-FEI LI: So Cloud
already has a suite
of APIs for a lot of
our industry partners
and customers, from Translate
to Speech to Vision.
DIANE GREENE: Which are
based on models we build.
FEI-FEI LI: Yes.
For example, Box
is a major partner
with Google Cloud where they
recognize a tremendous need
for organizing customers'
imagery data to help customers.
So they actually use Google's
Vision API to do that.
And that's a model easily
delivered to our customers
through our service.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah,
it's pretty exciting.
I mean, Greg, how do you
think that's going to play out
in the health industry?
I know you've been
thinking about that.
GREG CORRADO: So health
care is one of the problems
that a bunch of people
are working on at Google,
and a lot of people are working
on outside as well, because I
think there's a huge opportunity
to use these technologies
to expand the availability and
the accuracy of health care.
And part of that is because
doctors today are basically
trying to weather an
information hurricane in order
to provide care.
And so I think
there are thousands
of individual opportunities to
make doctors' work more fluid,
to build tools to solve
problems that they want solved,
and to do things
that help patients
and improve patient care.
DIANE GREENE: I mean, I
think you were telling me
that so many doctors are
so unhappy because they
have so much drudgery to do.
Is this a big breakthrough?
GREG CORRADO: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I believe that
there's been a great--
when you go to a doctor, you're
looking for medical attention.
And right now a huge
amount of their attention
is not actually focused on
the practice of medicine,
but is focused on a
whole bunch of other work
that they have to do
that doesn't require
the kind of insights
and care and connection
the real practice
of medicine does.
And so I believe that
machine learning and AI
is going to come
in for health care
through assistive technologies
that help the doctors do
what they want to do better.
DIANE GREENE: By understanding
what they do in a system.
No substitute for the humans.
GREG CORRADO: No.
FEI-FEI LI: No substitutes.
DIANE GREENE: Speaking
of human, Fei-Fei,
do you want to talk a
little bit about why
you think this humanistic
AI approach is so critical?
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah.
Thank you.
So if we look at the history
of AI, we've entered phase two.
The first 60 years is AI as more
or less a niche technical field
where we're still laying
down scientific foundations.
But starting this
point on, AI is
one of the biggest drivers
of societal changes to come.
So how do we think about
AI in the next phase?
What is the frame of mind
that should be driving
us has been on top of my mind.
And I think deeply about the
need for human-centered AI,
which in my opinion, includes
three elements to complete
the human-center AI thinking.
The first element is really
advancing AI to the next stage.
And here we bring our
collective background
from neuroscience,
cognitive science.
Whether we're getting to
AGI tomorrow or in 50 years,
there is a need for AI to be
a lot more flexible, nuanced,
learn faster, and
more unsupervised,
semi-supervised
[INAUDIBLE] learning ways
to be able to
understand emotion,
communicate with humans.
So that is the more
human-centered way
of advancing AI science.
The second part is the
human-center AI technology
and application is that I love
what you're saying that there's
no substitute for humans.
This technology,
like all technology,
is to enhance humans, to augment
humans, not to replace humans.
We'll replace certain tasks.
We'll replace humans out of
danger or tasks that we cannot
perform.
But the bottom line is we can
use AI to help our doctors,
to help our disaster
relief workers,
to help decision makers.
So there is a lot of
technology in robotics,
in design, in natural
language processing that
is centered around
human-centered AI
technology and application.
The third element
of human-centered AI
is really to combine
the thinking of AI
as a technology as well
as the societal impact.
We are so nascent in seeing
the impact of this technology.
But already, like
Diane said, that we
are seeing the impact
in different ways, ways
that we might not even predict.
So I think it's
really important.
And it's a responsibility
of everyone
from academia to
industry to government
to bring social
scientists, philosophers,
law scholars, policy
makers, ethicists,
and historians at the table and
to study more deeply about AI's
social and humanistic impact.
And that is the three
elements of human-centered AI.
DIANE GREENE: That's
pretty wonderful.
And I think we at Google here,
Alphabet, are working as hard
as we can to do humanistic AI.
You mentioned what we need
to be careful about out there
with AI and regulatory.
What are some of
the barriers to--
I think every
company in the world
has a use for AI
in many, many ways.
I mean, it's just exploding
in all the verticals.
But there are some
impediments to adoption.
For example, in the
financial industry
they need to have something
called explainable AI.
And could you just talk about
some of the different barriers
you see to being able
to take advantage of AI?
FEI-FEI LI: We should
start with health care.
GREG CORRADO: Yeah,
so I think that there
are a bunch of really
important things to consider.
So one of the things
is, of course, we
want to have machine
learning systems that
are designed to fit the
needs of the folks that are
using them and applying them.
And that can often include
not just giving me the answer,
but telling me something
about how that was derived.
So some kind of explainability.
So in the health care
space, for example,
we've been working on a bunch
of things in medical imaging.
And it's not acceptable to
just tell the doctor that,
oh, something looks
fishy in this x-ray
or this pathology slide
or this retinal scan.
You have to tell them, well,
what do you think is wrong?
But more importantly,
you actually
have to show them
where in the image
you think the evidence
for that conclusion
lies so that they
can then look at it
and decide whether they
concur or they disagree
or, oh, well, there was
a speck of dust there
and that's what the
machine is picking up on.
And the good news is that these
things actually are possible.
And I think there's kind of
been this unfortunate mythology
that AI and deep learning in
particular is a black box.
And it really isn't.
We didn't study how it worked,
because for a long time
it really didn't work that well.
But now that it's
working well, there
are a lot of tools
and techniques
that go into examining
how these systems work.
And I think explainability
is a big part of it
in terms of making these
things available for a bunch
of applications.
FEI-FEI LI: So in addition
to the explainability,
I would add bias.
I think bias is an issue
we need to address in AI.
And I see bias, from where I
sit, two major kind of bias
we need to address.
One is the pipeline
of AI development,
starting from the
bias of the data
to the outcome of the bias.
And we have heard a lot
about if the machine learning
algorithm is fed with data that
does not represent the problem
domain in a fair way,
we will introduce bias.
Whether it's missing a
group of people's data
or biasing it to a
skewed distribution,
those are things that would
have deep consequences,
whether you're in the health
care domain or finance
or legal decision making.
So I think that is a huge
issue very nicely that Google
is already addressing that.
We have a whole team at
Google working on bias.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah.
That's true.
FEI-FEI LI: And another
bias I think is important
is the people who
are developing AIs.
The human bias and the lack of
diversity is also another bias.
DIANE GREENE: It's so important.
And that kind of brings
me to maybe some of our--
we're getting close to the end.
But where is AI going?
I mean, how prevalent
is it going to be?
I mean, we look at our
universities and these machine
learning classes have
800 people, 900 people.
There is such a demand.
Every computer science
graduate wants to know it.
Where is it going?
I mean, will every high
school graduating senior
be able to customize AI
to their own purposes?
And what does it look like
five, 10 years from now?
FEI-FEI LI: So from a
technology point of view,
I think that because of
the tremendous investment
in resource, both in
the private sector
as well in the
public sector now,
many countries are waking
up to investing AI,
we're going to see a
huge continue development
of AI technology.
I'm mostly excited
either at Cloud
or seeing what
Greg's team is doing,
AI being delivered to the
industries that really
matter to people's lives and the
work quality and productivity.
But Diane, I think
you're also asking
is how are we educating
more people in AI?
DIANE GREENE: Both
making it easier to use
and educating them and
what's it going to look like?
What do you predict?
FEI-FEI LI: That's a
really tough question,
because at the core of
today's AI is still calculus.
And that's not going to change.
GREG CORRADO: So I think that
from the kind of tech industry
perspective or from the computer
science education perspective,
I think that we're going
to see AI and ML become
as essential as networking is.
No one really thinks
about, oh, well,
I'm going to write
some software and it's
going to be standalone on
a box and it's not going
to have a TCPI connection.
We all know that
you're going to have
a TCPI connection at the
end of the day somewhere.
And everyone understands the
basics of the networking stack.
And that's not just at
the level of engineers.
That's the level of
designers, of executives,
of product developers
and leaders.
And the same thing,
I think, is going
to happen with machine
learning and AI, which
is that designers are going to
start to understand, how can I
make a completely revolutionary
kind of product that folds
in machine learning the same
way that we fold in networking
and internet technologies into
almost everything we build?
So I think we're going
to see tremendous uptake
and it becoming kind of
a pervasive background
part of the technologies.
But I think in that
process the ways
that we use AI are
going to evolve.
So I think right
now we're seeing
a lot of things where
AI and machine learning
add some spice, some extra, a
little coolness on a feature.
And I think that what
you're going to see over
the next decade is
you're going to see more
of a core integration into
what it means for the product
to actually work.
And I think that one of
the great opportunities
there is actually going
to be the development
of artificial
emotional intelligence
that allows products to actually
have much more natural and much
more fluid human interaction.
We're beginning to see that in
the Assistant now with speech
recognition, speech
synthesis, understanding
dialogues and exchanges.
But I think that this
is still in its infancy.
We're going to get to a
point where the products
that we build, they interact
with humans in the way
that the humans find most
useful just out of the box.
FEI-FEI LI: And I spend a lot
of time with high schoolers,
because I really
believe in the future.
We always talk about
AI changing the world.
And I always say the question
is, who is changing AI?
And to me, bringing more
human mission thinking
into technology development
and thought leadership
is really important.
Not only important
for the future
of our technology and the value
we instill in our technology,
but also in bringing the
diverse group of students
and future leaders into
the development of AI.
So at [? Server ?] at Google,
we all work a lot on this issue.
And personally,
I'm very involved
with AI4ALL, which
is a nonprofit that
educates high schoolers
around the country
from diverse backgrounds,
whether they're
girls or students of
underrepresented minority
groups.
And we bring them
onto university campus
and work with them on AI
thinking and AI studies.
DIANE GREENE: And
at Google, we're
just completely committed
to bringing all our best
technologies to
everybody in the world.
And we're doing that
through the cloud,
and we're bringing
these tools, we're
bringing these APIs
and the training
and the partnering
and the processors.
And we're pretty excited
to see what all you
guys are going to do with it.
Thank you very much.
GREG CORRADO: Thanks, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]